[Music]
hey you guys
yeah we started a little bit early just
because we were sick of sitting here
we're miserable last night we drank a
lot the show was [ __ ]
six hours long show
what they call a full ass show and some
in some parts of the world
and um then we get up
and it's valentine's day
go out to the restaurant go to [ __ ]
red lobster try tonight
got some fish and chips and chowder
that's simple clam chowder yeah
it's pretty good but it was actually
really good but
stuffed i'm just yeah i just can't eat
well because you know i've been dieting
for so long i keep feeling my stomach is
shrank down to nothing so now anytime i
i eat like a restaurant meal i'm like oh
i'm gonna pee
yeah it sucks and it's like so good and
i can't finish it
i checked last night's show and [ __ ] the
second part two
starts off me sitting there with a damn
bowl of bucket of ham
of ham yeah you got like this
oh that's when you know it's a good show
when tom's eating ham at the first
yeah everybody said it's a good show i
guess i thought it was [ __ ] long and
it was better they started to lose track
of what the [ __ ] was going on it was a
fun topic i think is why
i mean you know some people were
bitching about it that [ __ ] you
couldn't get it worded in
edgewise i i don't know it just to me it
just sounds like i was talking maybe
they just
i don't know maybe it's cancer culture i
don't [ __ ] know what it is no one's
canceling you trying to cancel me
i don't know what it is i'm just saying
you know what i mean [ __ ] we're on
the show we're talking
when we start drinking look let's show
that book jenny
show your show them your book oh yeah
how big this guy i ordered a copy of
this for one of our
one of our people i don't think they're
here i think their name is donovan
and he wanted a signed copy of one of my
books so i had to order it so i could
sign it
i this is the first time i've had like a
print copy of this
look how [ __ ] this is the chunky boy
yeah look how big that thing look at how
[ __ ] big i didn't realize i'm like
holy [ __ ] crap man now some of it's
like the bibliography i'm not gonna lie
that's a good book but this is why i i
wanted
her to show this to you if i don't get a
word in edgewise that show's gonna be
like that and the notes for her
shows are almost this big she's a writer
you [ __ ] just cut her loose she's
going to take off
she's going to take over i got to say
hold on
and then say something if not that's
what's going to be like
that's what the show's going to be all
right so there's a there's a method to
my [ __ ] madness
i know her we've been together 10 years
i know her yeah
yeah but i just wanted to show this i
don't know if you're i don't know if
you're out there donovan but i just got
the
book today so i'm going to sign it and
i'll mail it out to you tomorrow
right and another one of those is coming
yeah as soon as we get done with the and
and we're uh making real good progress
on the cookbook
man we got all we just we did all the
stuff i did all this transcription so
now all i have to do is just go in there
and put it all
yeah i mean the first like almost like
third of it is done
adjust some of the [ __ ] photos and
then we gotta do a photo shoot
for kitties i'm gonna put myself in
there and have some channels probably
gonna be in it and it
and then it'll it'll be ready to print
it won't yeah it's still
weeks away but it's it's the heavy
lifting i think is gone it's done well i
would say weeks or months
that was yeah i mean that was the i
think that was the hardest part was just
like sitting down in here and recording
you talking about all the recipes
and [ __ ] and then uh i just i got a
service
to transcribe all of it so i didn't have
to you know what i mean or like a you
know an ai
yeah to transcribe it for 13 bucks or
whatever it was so i didn't have to
[ __ ] type it
but uh all right let's not do like too
long a thing because
my my stomach is really really
all right full and like and i'm really
really sleepy
my friend my friend khan avatsalon the
ultimate ricardo monteblonde down in
tijuana
he's a big nicholas cage fan he's like
me i like nic cage too
everybody likes that cage and he's put
put me out of two movies all right
the first one i saw it was jiu jitsu jiu
jitsu which is the one we were we are
discussing
today the other one i'm going to watch
tonight is a new
nicholas cage movie that looks a lot
better than this one actually
it's called uh willy's wonderland
which sounds dirty it's
nicholas cage nicholas cage starring
nick cage
he should just be nick cage in every
single movie that should just be the
character's name
yeah might as well yeah my name is nick
cage and i'm here to [ __ ]
anyway this is my movie so he's uh
in the from what i've seen in uh
willie's wonderland
he gets hired to clean up this kind of
like a fun house
and when he gets in there he he finds
out that he's there to be a human
sacrifice
i hate when that happens and he's being
attacked by damn
animatronic robots so we're gonna see
you know are they satanic animatronics
yeah
like jack in the boxes and [ __ ] weird
[ __ ] like that all right i like the
scene
yeah it looked crazy as [ __ ] and there
is
a few seconds you can see the trailer on
youtube
we're gonna watch that one tonight
probably you can see the on trailer him
they made sure that there's at least
like five or six seconds of cage caging
the [ __ ] out
caging the [ __ ] out is a thing that's
just when you're going
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know the bees or whatever
sometimes the one he did in mandy was
probably the most epic caging
oh yeah he caged the [ __ ] out and that
one that i mean that whole movie is just
one long cage
maddie's that masterpiece if you guys
it's like an acid trip it's a nicolas
cage acid tree i love that movie
yeah we even have uh in our in our room
by the bed we even have like a big silk
poster yeah like it's like hot pink and
it's
cool from the mandy movie yeah so
so this one is called jiu jitsu yeah and
like you said connor batson
turned us on to this one you can't i
don't know somebody said you could
you could rent it on youtube for five
dollars um on amazon prime you can only
buy it but it's also five dollars
so we were like ah what the hell um now
i will say
okay this is a sci-fi movie it's
essentially a predator rip-off i mean
yeah it knows it is it yeah that's
exactly what it is
yeah uh what was funny is that okay what
what
what the setup here is is
soldiers and jedis
fighting the [ __ ] predator yeah
that's
what it is and nick cage is the wise man
who's already fought the predator and
lived
it's [ __ ] ridiculous all right oh pat
how philos have we talked about color
out of space yet we did we reviewed
colorado because
yeah because we have the blu-ray it's
good some people didn't like it
it's on shutter too it's good yeah i
liked it at least it's got its own thing
you know it's yeah i liked mandy better
probably like of those two but i mean
it was it was a really good uh hp
lovecraft adaptation that's for sure
but yeah so this starts out okay so
there's a dude who's a he's named jake
right
i think that dude is a stunt man he's in
real good shape
yeah i think he's a martial artist and
he's like
running through the woods um and having
cgi things thrown at them are they
type things i couldn't tell what they
were the [ __ ] that the alien was
throwing
yeah okay and he's he's he's supposed to
be i guess you could hit your stand in
for
arnold schwarzenegger slash jean claude
van damme he's he's like a combination
of the two
you know he's his own thing it's just
he'd have been [ __ ] great back in the
80s had he appeared back then but now
you know what i mean just
they're not gonna put guys like that in
[ __ ] really good movies what the hell
was that
is that is it storming or is it pookie
trying to get in the door
the door's not shut yeah she could open
she can walk in she's strong
but um yeah and then there's uh
this is taking place in burma oh yeah
that's what i forgot about yeah
and somehow or another a bunch of burma
burmese
uh martial artists [ __ ] get involved
in this and they're trying to they fight
the soldiers and they're trying to fight
the predator
they're not burmese soldiers so they're
burmese [ __ ] martial artists
and they're they're they're obviously
supposed to be jedi
obviously and they're even called
somebody says oh so the jedi are now
doing yeah i think even that
like military lady like that army
intelligence lady calls him jedi so
we're like oh okay just you got us a
movie
yeah he didn't have some interesting
camera shots of like
uh point of view [ __ ] kung fu
[ __ ] scenes turns out
nick cage tells everybody that jiu jitsu
actually is an
alien martial art that that yeah they
gave it to us
um god gave jiu jitsu to
all right well wait so what ended up
happening this
okay so the story was i was a little
fuzzy on this yeah this
story didn't really matter there was
like a temple yeah yeah and it had like
a portal and every six years for
whatever reason
the portal would open when a comet goes
over yeah it's a comet there's that
whole thing
and then the alien would come through
the portal and want to fight so
the aliens fight great great [ __ ]
monster yeah so the alien initially came
to earth
and taught people jiu jitsu so that he
would have somebody to fight when he
came here
he says you know what is the point of
him coming here and fighting i don't
really know
um but if you don't come forward and
fight him
um and you don't kill him though they
just fight right and then he just like
fights and he's like okay fair enough
and then he goes back home
uh no he was killing people too he was
killing people if if uh
if you if you showed any cowardice
remember he was killing people that's
right he was killing innocent people
well he would yeah he would kill
innocent people if you didn't like come
and
jiu jitsu it and it's kind of obvious
that the portal he was coming through
was this thing was borrowed right from
stargate yeah it's like right
stargate that's somebody pitched this
movie
as predators with mercenaries ninjas
and a stargate and oh and
but not i have to say not quite as fun
as that sounds yeah
it when it started it was kind of zany
but then as it went it tried to get a
little bit more
serious but the way the predator worked
the way the predator looked it looked
like the guyver
and it borrowed directly from the guy it
was kind of cool looking
kind of a face that was just a big furry
ball and you could see the face
it was just like a light yeah and then
you can see behind it was the face that
kind of looked like
master control from [ __ ] tron or a
pig
i thought it looked a little bit like
this or like tad from
funhouse or or the zuni warrior face
yeah from the trilogy of terror it kind
of looked like that you couldn't really
see it it was almost kind of like
i don't know it was like a light-up face
they never really showed it yeah and
then like the eyes were red
but yeah it was kind of like it looked
like that it did really look like the
guy
to me it reminded me of master control
from tron at first remember how that
little [ __ ] beam that came down into
a nexus and it was just a big
rainbow [ __ ] a
[ __ ] cylinder of energy with a face
in it yeah whatever
and the face in that thing just kind of
reminded me of it i don't know
because it was in a light i guess yeah
but
oh also um this had a
[Music]
uh wise kraken uh character
who was played by the dude who played
crab man on my name is earl
i didn't i didn't see that one okay my
neighbors are always like funny it was a
yeah it was a show years ago that that
was on i think he was in would you
rather as well if i'm not
mistaken i like that guy highlight of
the movie
was nick cage i mean turn the [ __ ] out
and do
doing doing cage the activities doing
occasionally activities
doing and doing cage jiu jitsu aliens or
at least his stunt double was i think it
was him
some of it was him but some of it i
don't know
i was kind of buying that he was doing
some of the fighting you know
yeah yeah yeah um
i think that was part of what made the
movie ludicrous i
i don't think it was the movie's not
supposed to be taken seriously if you
ask me it's
i've had a hard time telling whether or
not they're appealing to to
15 year olds or 50 year olds because
there's a mixture of both
because a lot of the stuff in it was
throwbacks to 80s action flicks
yeah which i understood i just didn't
know if i
feel like they should have gone wackier
with it though because they've been much
worse to be honest i feel i mean because
the premise of it is so ludicrous
yeah that i think that you should have
just leaned into it because i kind of
felt like
i kind of felt like you know there was
funny [ __ ] in it but
not enough funny [ __ ] to make me think
that
they weren't actually trying to have it
to be taken seriously what happened to
it
so the tone of it was very strange the
tone of it was uneven
that first one quarter of it it seems
zany and kind of fun with a bunch of
[ __ ] kung fu
the kung fu gets tiresome because there
isn't much dialogue
it's just one dude fighting the next and
i'm going this is for 15 year olds
they just keep [ __ ] fighting now
there are some cool camera angles it
looks like
first person fighting and weird [ __ ]
funny [ __ ] happens
it looks like a video game in parts like
in the sense that
like a first person like a first person
shooter type of video like they do some
shots like that yeah like as though you
were playing a video game it's like hey
here's my arm something like that some
of the dialogue is [ __ ]
ludicrous looking and it's got subtitles
like on
john wick so they try to do john wick
there's a little bit of john wick in
there too
but then it kind of starts getting a
little bit like it's trying to be a
serious movie which foils it because
it's
it's obviously [ __ ] ludicrous what
you're seeing
that's what i'm saying they should keep
reeling up in it and to get the humor
going
like velocipaster yeah that's what they
really gold standard
that's the gold standard like i said
you can compress a turd until it becomes
a diamond
yeah [ __ ] velocipaster is a [ __ ]
proof
i will say that and i think i mentioned
this last night that um
you know the movie is called jiu-jitsu
and you will indeed see a lot of
jiu-jitsu in it
probably too much jiu-jitsu um if i'm
being honest
yeah because i was just kind of like and
because the movie is not short
it's like it's 102 minutes yeah and it
could have been
oh man it could have been it could have
been like 85 yeah it could have been
half the
tops seriously what happens with [ __ ]
long extended kung fu scenes
is that it it starts becoming boring and
repetitious
yeah and i think this is suffered a
little bit from that
it loses its impact effort after a
couple seconds
and i mean really any time nicholas cage
or crab man wasn't on
i really um i didn't know any of the
other characters names
um didn't matter or their deal because
like nobody hardly talked and when they
did it was just i was kind of like who's
this now is this
yeah yeah like what happened why is this
happening yeah yeah who's this now it's
like i sounded like
i sounded like him like an old guy at
the moment who's this now what's going
on i kind of sounded like that
well it's just kind of like and i wasn't
even drinking man i was just like
watching this [ __ ]
but um i don't know like i feel like
nicolas cage should have been in it more
because he was in it for like a second
at the beginning
and then he wasn't in it again until
like halfway through the movie
yeah i just i and he was a delight
when he was in it but i feel like he
wasn't in it enough because i was just
kind of like all these other people like
here are all these other boring people
fighting the guyver and all right
you know what i mean they're near joker
the same aliens who built the pyramids
gave his kung fu
evidently yeah i don't know if they did
they built the pyramids
no no that wasn't wait did they did they
even say that that wouldn't surprise me
if that was in there but i don't think
that was in there didn't say that they
they evidently built some of those like
burmese
structures because they had a damn
stargate in it
yeah so some of the burmese i mean why
do you think like why
would an alien just he's like man i'm
gonna build this whole [ __ ] apparatus
and like every six years every time a
comic comes by or whatever
i'm gonna go to that earth planet and
i'm just gonna like do some martial arts
on some people
then i'm gonna get killed except not
really yeah because well that's the
thing like at the end
and i'm not worried about doing spoiler
alert because it's like this isn't the
kind of thing that you're watching like
for a big twist or anything but the
thing about it is like so at the end
they what they did like they put the
grenade
inside him and then because he couldn't
he can heal up so he's like kind of a
cheater
i'll i'll say that right now um so they
put the grenade in there and then the
kind of blue and he kind of blew up and
then they like kicked him into the
stargate
yeah and then crabman said see you in
six years
yeah so i'm like so he's like he could
come back or was it a different one
i don't know was it like a predator
thing where it wasn't the same one
i don't know i was confused something
they just made up because i thought it
sounded cool
but it is basically the alien looks like
the guyver look like the guy
it's not a bad looking alien i gotta say
like the suit's pretty cool and [ __ ]
like that's obviously a suit
but well yeah it is obviously a suit but
they didn't really try to make it look
like and like anything other than it was
supposed to be a suit i guess it wasn't
supposed to be biological
but anyway it um
it's definitely the predator i mean it
sees in the [ __ ]
uh uh infrared like when you see
all the stuff down on the side it can
can cloak itself and be invisible oh
yeah it did yeah
it cloaks itself too it was throwing the
little throwing stars
you know you know like some some of the
predators did i think in it predators
versus alien
they had the one it was like made like
turn into like a big starfish
um what else did it did it have
it didn't have a gun did yeah i think it
did have a gun didn't it
uh but then it also did jujitsu yeah it
was mostly a jiu jitsu
yeah mango says wait there's a mutant
crab man in this movie no i'm just
calling him crabman because i can't
remember that actor's name
that's the part that i know that was the
part that i knew it from it's like
it was crap man on my name do i
recommend this movie
no i don't know like if you really like
nicholas cage then maybe skip to like
the halfway point and watches
it's funny because i was reading a
review of it and somebody compared
his look and like his kind of you know
the way he's spazzing out and everything
like to kind of dennis hopper's thing
and
apocalypse now he did kind of look like
that he had like the long hair and the
[ __ ]
lover boy headband and there's a lot of
nick cage movies out there
all right yeah because that [ __ ] will
be in and there are good ones yeah
this isn't really one of them and it's
it's not really one of the good ones
because he's not into it a whole lot
yeah he was
in it a lot more than i'd say yeah
and yeah he needed to be in like the
whole thing he needed to be like the
main character thing but evidently they
couldn't afford to pay him to be the
whole
the whole thing he's probably in
15 minutes of it maybe huh 20 minutes of
it yeah maybe 20 minutes over being
generous
because like i said he doesn't really
show up like he pulls jake
oh because jake also i forgot that
aspect
jake also has amnesia because at the
very beginning when he's running away
from the gyver
he falls off a cliff jumps off a cliff i
can't remember and he hits his head on a
rock
and gets amnesia yeah and so he doesn't
remember
what the [ __ ] is going on or who all
these people are why there's an alien
thrown [ __ ] at him or he doesn't
remember
any of that yeah right so there's that
whole aspect too
i just kind of i feel like this like i
said the premise of it is so crazy
that they should have just owned it and
they should have like just leaned into
words like we're just gonna make this
[ __ ] wacky ass it would have been a
lot funnier
yeah wacky and it had the potential for
having a lot more sex appeal
because if it's wacky you could do stuff
like put [ __ ]
scantily clad big busted [ __ ]
mercenary girls in it
[Laughter]
when you run yeah yeah you could do you
could go that angle this
because it's you're not trying to go to
realism this only has like
only a couple women in it and they don't
really play
an interesting role at all they're not
funny and they're not really sexy so
just you know what i mean [ __ ]
this type of movie what they were
shooting for was supposed to be
like dumb and fun and [ __ ] and
pulling 15
15 year old boys and 50 year old 50 year
old little boys at the same time
and a lot more [ __ ] scared yeah and
like i said i just feel like it should
have been crazier because i
i got the impression that until nicholas
cage showed up i got the impression that
they were
trying to make a straight faced serious
sci-fi movie and they didn't really have
the money to do that obviously
i mean the special effects aren't awful
they're not yeah but they're not that
great either because you can tell it's
really really local
it's the storyboard stuff too when it
started so i'm going to the comic book
yeah
so that was cool i liked that like and
the way it started it was good
um i go this is okay it's gonna be a
comic book movie but then it kind of
and it had kind of a comic book feel to
it at first but then it
it's like they forgot about that yeah
that's what i mean but just the tone of
it
just didn't really match yeah i needed a
bunch of editing
yeah and it needed uh a better
soundtrack more funny
more than maybe like a couple the movie
could have been fixed
yeah but i'm not sure if this was
i don't know i don't want to say i don't
know if it was a high effort movie you
have to put a lot of effort out to make
any movie even a shitty one
it's just i think maybe i think maybe
there was maybe there's some
disagreement about what kind of movie
this was
when they were yeah that's kind of the
impression that i got right i mean
so i just kind of feel like so a lot of
it i just felt like was kind of
boring yeah especially but mindless yeah
like a lot of the jiu jitsu scenes just
went on like way too long and
yeah i was just kind of like okay i get
it you know
let's move on um but yeah it's kind of a
shame i mean
missed opportunity yeah i feel like they
should just take the part that had
nicolas cage in it and just make that a
short film
yeah or have some bunch of this out put
some more storyboarded stuff
with with a funny soundtrack maybe
[ __ ] add a few seeds
to to kind of put yeah
yeah it needed it needed a better edit
i think yeah it just it for sure should
have been shorter yeah because it was it
just went on too long i thought
but i'm looking forward to seeing um
uh willy wonder willie's wonderland that
uh
looks like a decent nic cage movie that
sounds super fun
it looks like and then it's a horror
movie i guess horror comedy
or you know how anything's gonna have
cages even it's gonna have an element of
comedy even
mandy did yeah it just looks like
something that
that is like to possibly to the caliber
of mandy
not visually but still good i mean i
don't want to say
not using mandy's visual style but
quality wise this
could might be as good as mandy we'll
see well and like i said if i'm going to
see like a shitty
movie or like a low budget movie i'm
always like a bigger fan of
horror than sci-fi and honestly if you
don't have money
don't try to make a sci-fi movie you're
just gonna shoot yourself in the dick
yeah just don't do that just protest
well yeah that's what i mean
don't do that
that's what i mean you just shouldn't do
that i mean sci-fi is just too difficult
i mean unless you're doing you know like
a different kind of sci-fi
like it's not it's set in space or
whatever but you know unless you're
doing like the vast of night
i mean you know that worked but i don't
know i feel like a lot of sci-fi
you kind of need a lot of money for that
kind of [ __ ] like real ambitious
i think badgers telling me he had the
feeling that they only had cage for a
couple days of shooting i kind of got
that impression what it might have been
it might have been a situation yeah oh
well what are you gonna do i think he's
talking about this movie because he's
talking about another movie in there too
with somebody else yeah
so yeah i don't think he was on it for
very long yeah just
wham bam thank you man gave him his cash
and he [ __ ] left
something like that yeah so we'll watch
that tonight probably
yeah we'll either do a matinee on it
tomorrow or i still want to do a matinee
on uh ouija
and ouija origin of evil because we
watch those as well
so uh that'll probably says get ready
tom and
jenny because nick cage doesn't talk in
it interesting
okay now i'm intrigued okay
yeah all right so uh you have anything
else you would like to add
you're getting kind of sleepy yeah me
too there's like too many carbs
just my stomach hurts and yeah holy crap
i'm gonna have my i'm gonna have my
valentine's day hot chocolate in my new
little mug
my new little mug with a little heart on
it oh i have to show the valentine's day
card that tom got me because it's like
as cute as [ __ ] look at this
look at this it's a bouquet of kittens
oh my gosh and it's like 3d
check it out like kitty heads coming at
you
[Laughter]
all right so uh yeah so we'll see you
guys again tomorrow
about three o'clock and we'll see you
then thanks for dropping by
bye